and we're live what's going on did you
sleep well last night I did
I didn't sleep badly I mean hotels are a
tough thing and we actually know the
science that one half of your brain will
actually not sleep as deeply than the
other when you're sleeping in an unusual
room like a hotel room really that's
what [ __ ] me up when I'm on the road
you know I'll do three different hotels
in a week because I'll do like a
Thursday Friday Saturday like with gigs
and then by the time Sunday rolls around
I'm a mess in rough shape yeah is that
what it is
yeah and it's a you mean it's a threat
detection thing I mean if you look at
other species they can do this much more
impressively than we can
so dolphins or any sort of sea dwelling
mammal can actually sleep with half a
brain so one half of that brain goes
into deep sleep the other half is wide
awake that's how people the DMV do it
those people that work at the Department
of Motor Vehicles they're there they
work half asleep you ever meet them I
haven't no teasing your DMV listening
going [ __ ] you man next time you're
coming to get your license renewed
there's my next NIH grant I think
looking at the DMV and sleep but yeah we
si workers same thing same same type of
human that I've come across yeah damn -
I'm just kidding [ __ ] relax so when
you're in a hotel room what is happening
that you're half your brain is not
really sleeping yes so there's different
stages of sleep there are two principle
types one is non rapid eye movement
sleep or non REM sleep the other is REM
sleep which is also known as dream sleep
right and non-rapid eye movement sleep
is further divided into four separate
stages which are unimaginative Lee
called stages one through four we're a
creative bunch as much as it is true but
I think it's also although IQ but it's
the deep stages of sleep three and four
of that non-rapid eye movement that's
where a lot of sort of body
replenishment takes place brings the
cardiovascular system metabolism all of
those good things but that's the deep
sleep that
half of your brain will resist going
into when you're sleeping in a foreign
environment so it stays in this kind of
lighter stage almost like a threat
detection system and you can imagine why
you know it's an unusual context
evolutionarily it would make a lot of
sense to just have that sort of on guard
one half of the brain that makes so much
sense and that really for me it fills in
the blanks of like why even if I get you
know seven eight hours sleep on the road
I'm still kind of just out of it
yeah and that's in fact probably one of
the I think the most impressive parts of
new research on sleep it's not just
about quantity it's also about quality
and quality can be as detrimental if you
don't get it as a reduction in total
quality I mean both are essential right
but I think it speaks exactly to your
point you just don't feel like it's a
refreshing sort of deep sleep yeah it
feels totally different um it just feels
like I guess I would say it feels like
half asleep yeah it's really kind of
does feel yeah one of the things that I
noticed I did this thing with my friends
called sober October where we didn't
smoke any pot or do any no drinking at
all nothing for a month and when I did
it one of the things I found was that
after about I don't know how many days
but it was noticeable that I would have
these incredibly vivid dreams and then I
had read that marijuana does something
to suppress heavy REM sleep like what
what is happening there yeah so both of
those chemicals both of which it used as
a sleep aid alcohol and marijuana are
actually very good at blocking your
dream sleep your rapid eye movement
sleep and so what happens is that the
brain is quite clever in this regard it
builds up a clock counter of how much
dream sleep you should have had but have
not been getting and it starts to
develop this increasing appetite and
hunger for dream sleep so that finally
when the alcohol actually gets out of
your system sober October over the name
that's all of a sudden where you get
what's called a REM sleep rebound effect
where you not only get the normal amount
of REM sleep that you would normally
have
get that plus the brain tries to get
back some of that dream sleep that it's
been losing over the past maybe 11 11
months so you get this 20 years serum so
you get this REM sleep rebounded effect
and that's where you have these really
intense dream sleep situations yeah the
same reason that people will they'll say
like I had a bit too much to drink last
night maybe it was a Friday or Saturday
they sleep in late they say I just had
these crazy dreams mmm what happens
there is a kind of an acute version
where the alcohol is swirling around in
your system and after about six hours
your liver and your kidneys have finally
excreted all of the alcohol and your
brain has been deprived of dream sleep
for that first six hours so then it
feasts in the last couple of hours and
that's why you have these really bizarre
dreams after you've been drinking a
little bit too much oh wow so but what
is happening with marijuana though
specifically do you know yeah so
marijuana it does help people will help
it it puts people to sleep quicker
although I think that the question is
whether it's really natural istic sleep
or not that they go into certainly with
alcohol it's not that nightcap idea is
is a misnomer alcohol will actually well
it's a form of drugs that we call the
sedatives and sedation is not sleep it's
very different but we often mistake one
for the other marijuana it seems to act
in a physiologically very different way
it doesn't target the same receptors in
the brain so it's unclear whether this
speed with which you fall asleep after
having a session with marijuana is
actually natural sleep let's assume it
is the problem however is that it then
will start to disrupt REM sleep it will
start to block the process we think
perhaps at the level of the brainstem
which is were these two types of sleep
non REM and REM sleep will actually get
sort of worked out that's where
marijuana may actually impact dream
sleep and shut it down and block it have
there been any Studies on chronic
marijuana smokers like those
dawn-to-dusk type characters that just
are constantly high like and what
happens to their brain from not because
they must never hit REM sleep he
so people haven't looked at marijuana
they have looked at alcohol though mmm
exactly that so what happens is if you
look at alcoholics they will have
something often when they come off
alcohol something called delirium
tremens which is where the sort of DT
there what happens is that the alcohol
has been blocking dream sleep for so
long and the pressure for dream sleep is
built up so powerfully in the brain it
actually just spills over into
wakefulness and so the brain just says
look okay if I'm not going to get this
dream sleep whilst you're asleep I'm
just going to take it whilst you're
awake and so you start to essentially
dream while you're awake it's this sort
of collision of two states of
consciousness so you get delirium Wow I
always thought the DTS were detoxing
other when someone said someone's going
through those three T's okay yeah so
it's delirium tremor yeah delirium
tremens yeah I'm sort of mmm so what
like what is going on with them when
this is happening so if they are going
through this delirium during the day
while they're conscious what what's
physiologically happening so it's almost
as though the veil of REM sleep gets
pulled over the waking brain as it were
so you have this mixed state of
consciousness that you can pick up with
brainwave recordings and it just tells
me I mean in some ways how necessary
sleep must be if that's the lengths that
the brain will go to to get that which
it's been missing you know just shows
you why you know it took mother nature's
3.6 million years to put this thing
called any tower sleep necessity in
place and we've come along and within
the space of a hundred years we've
lopped off almost 20% of that if you
look at the data Wow really yeah and so
many people take pride in that too I
don't need a tower sleep
I got three I'm good ready to go kick
ass and dominate the world yeah yeah
it's the sort of like sleep machismo
attitude there's a lot of that right
yeah it's me baby I like sleep well I
mean you'd be glad to know that then you
know men who sleep five to six hours a
night will have a level of testosterone
which is that of someone ten years their
senior
hmm so a less tough sleep will aid you
by a decade in terms of the critical
aspect of wellness virility muscle
strength years that's incredible
Wow we had a woman on the podcast her
name is Courtney de Walter and she's a
ultra marathon runner and she ran she's
a real freak I mean like an incredible
athlete
she ran this thing called the Moab 240
its 238 miles through the the Moab
mountains and she did it 22 miles faster
than the second place man
so she wanted by like a whopping I think
it was ten hours ten hours ahead of the
second place winner and she slept one
minute one minute the entire time she
tried to lie to this over three days I
think it took her less than three days
thing took her like two days she slept
for one minute during the entire time
but she tried to lie down she said she
laid down for a few minutes but she
couldn't fall asleep and then she wound
up actually just taking one minute and
going to sleep and she said that one
minute was like one of the most intense
restful minutes after that minute is
over she was woken up cuz she told her
partner a running partner to wake her up
at a minute and she's like how long did
you let me sleep and he was like one
minute she's like wow I feel great let's
go but she was saying that she
hallucinates and that she starts seeing
like rabbits or talking to her and she
sees things that aren't there and like
mystical beings and stuff she said it's
really freaky but she knows that she's
hallucinating because she's done this
she's done a bunch of ultra marathons so
she just keeps going she just keeps
going and she's like saying hi to
rabbits they're talking orange stuff
yeah I mean and you you see these
reports too I mean there's a there's a
race of cycling race of things bike
across America you just got to go from
East Coast to west coast in a shorter
time as possible and that's exactly what
they do to it's all about managing how
little sleep that you get and they will
explain these wild hallucinogenic
experiences on the bike if you look at
world records for people who have tried
to sort of go without sleep and one of
the most famous examples is a radio disc
jockey called Peter
trip back in the news back in the sort
of 60s 50s 60s and he tried to break the
world record he went eight days straight
and yeah no sleep yeah he was
broadcasting from Times Square
and he would do his show there and you
know the scientists the psychiatrist
said look this is a very bad idea based
on what we know please don't do it and
he said I'm gonna do it anyway and then
the scientists being the good scientists
they said great Jemaine if we study you
could it'd be a great paper to sort of
you know to write up and they tracked
him and by day three he was having
florid delusions and hallucinations he
was seeing spiders in his shoes he
became desperately paranoid he started
to think that people were trying to
poison him in his food one point it was
the middle of winter some guys came in
with sort of these bears in New York
wintertime came in with these big
jackets he thought it was the Secret
Service coming to get him and he ran out
into the road huh you know these are
strangely but so we know that that same
profile of just starting to become you
know psychotic which is essentially what
happens naturally when you dream that
you are I mean all of us here you know
as long as we slept last night we came
flagrantly psychotic when we went into
dream sleep because you start to see
things which are not there so you
hallucinate you believe things that
couldn't possibly be true
so you're delusional you get confused
about time place in person so you're
suffering from disorientation you have
wildly fluctuating emotions something
that psychiatrists call being sort of
effectively labile and then how
wonderful we both woke up this morning
and we forgot most if not all of that
dream experience so we're suffering from
amnesia what is happening when you're
having these hallucinogenic experiences
like what are the chemicals that are
causing it do we know we do it yeah and
we so we've done some of these studies
where we put people into brain scanners
we let them fall asleep and then we see
what happens within the brain which
parts of the brain is switching on which
parts of the brain are switching off
when you go into REM sleep firstly some
parts of your brain become 30% more
active than when you're awake so it's
you know we think of sleep as this sort
of you know static passive
state where everything just kind of
drops down in terms of activity it's
quite the country but what's also
interesting is that not all parts of the
brain ramped up when you go into REM
sleep visual parts of the brain increase
motor parts of the brain increase
emotional centers and memory centers
they all increase but the part of the
brain that bucks the trend and goes in
the opposite direction is the part of
the brain that we call the prefrontal
cortex this sort of CEO of the brain
that's very good at rational logical
thinking that parts of that part of the
brain gets shut off so it's almost as
though you know that the prison guards
are gone and everyone runs amuck
because there's no controller you know
in place and so we know sort of from the
patterns of brain activity why you
become sort of so visual you see things
why you have motor kinesthetic activity
why things feel it's so emotional but
also why things seem utterly illogical
and irrational because your frontal
brain the thing that makes us most human
you can say goodbye to that for the rest
of dream sleep so there's no driver so
there's no driver yeah now why do we
forget why do we forget those dreams
because I I wake up and I am sure that
I'm gonna remember these dreams and
sometimes I do sometimes I remember and
I don't think I really remember them I
think what it is is very much like you
ever hears someone talk about a memory
from a long time ago
I used to think that people actually
remembered things from a long time ago
but now what I think is they remember
remembering it mmm I think they remember
talking about it they remember how they
described it and then they sort of
remember that and repeat it and in their
mind convinced themselves that that's
what happened because I've heard people
tell stories about the past and they're
they vary wildly from what is absolutely
true like like factual you could check
it you could research it you know what
the facts are but in their mind it's
very different and I think that it's
entirely possible that what people are
doing is remembering the recollection of
these memories and how they told them
and then also sort of people
library things that makes themselves
look better or make the situation look
more dramatic but with dreams that
doesn't make any sense so I was I'm
always trying to figure out like what is
it about a dream where sometimes I can
remember the dream and sometimes it's so
vivid when I wake up I'm like holy [ __ ]
that was crazy what a dream and then I
forget 20 minutes later right what is
that
so firstly I mean one theory of dreaming
is that it's just simply a
reconstruction when you wake up so you
have these fragments of activity and
what your cortex does when it wakes up
is what your cortex is designed to do
when you're awake normally which is try
to package everything can make a good
story make logical fit out of the world
that's one theory I don't believe that
though you your point is a very
interesting one do I remember my dreams
that doesn't necessarily mean I forget
my dreams and what I mean by that is
accessibility versus availability so if
you haven't had that experience where
you've woken up you thought I was
definitely dreaming I can't quite grab
it you know it just and it's gone mm-hmm
and then two days later you're in the
shower you said of washing yourself you
see a bottle of shampoo you see the
label and it just triggers the unlocking
of that dream memory and it sort of
comes flooding back or someone says
something to you you think oh that was
the dream yeah what that tells me as a
brain scientist is that the memory is
there it's preserved it's available but
what happens when most of the time when
we wake up is that we lose the IP
address to the memory so it's present
but it's not consciously accessible
available not accessible if that's true
what it means is that this type of
information we know can have
non-conscious impacts on our behavior
all the time there's great brain science
about this non conscious memory
processing it's possible that we store
every one of our dreams we just don't
consciously have accessibility to it but
nevertheless it's changing how we behave
how we feel each and every day no
evidence for it it's a theory I'm still
wanting to test but that's possible too
and it's only that anecdote where I can
think
just don't remember the dream I
forgotten it I don't think that may be
true it may still be there I just need
to find the keys to XOR to access that
memory what's stunning to me is how
quickly the dream evaporates the memory
of the dream in relation to an actual
experience like if we went outside and
we saw some lady walk up to some guy and
kick him in the balls we'd be like whoa
we would remember that and that you
needed to be able to tell your friends
like yeah some lady just randomly walked
us some guy and kicked him the balls
like we would remember that and you
would remember it ten minutes later
you'd remember in an hour you'd remember
it yes next day you'd be telling your
friends yeah she just walked right up to
him I remember it like it was yesterday
cuz it was right yeah but a dream gonna
be ten minutes ago and you wake up and
dude it was King Kong and he was he was
swinging from my ceiling and somehow
another thief it in the room but the
room got bigger and you have these crazy
dreams and then 20 minutes later you
forget all of it like what is happening
there so one-one current explanation is
that the chemistry of the brain when you
go into dream sleep is radically
different yeah so one of the chemicals
called noradrenaline in the brain which
downstairs in the body it's sister
chemical is called adrenaline
noradrenaline actually plummets to the
lowest levels it's actually it's a
stress chemical in the brain it's one of
them that gets shut off during dream
sleep which is even if you're managing
like what if you fall off a building
well what's interesting is that that
chemical is low-wealth you're having
that dream but when you wake up from
those and some people often wake up
that's when you have the spike of Norum
so it's still low when you're in dream
sleep
but there's another chemical that goes
in the opposite direction it's called
acetylcholine it's the chemical that is
actually an altered in Alzheimer's
disease and these two chemicals will
change essentially the input/output
direction of information flow into the
memory centers of the brain so that
makes sense because people take that as
a nootropic they do yeah that's actually
an alpha brain when when you take that
it's this been clinically proven to
enhance memory especially verbal memory
and recollection of words
things like that that's right so that's
happening while you're sleeping well
you're in REM sleep yeah but what may be
happening our current models if you sort
of build these neural models to sort of
mimic dreaming it may be that during
dreaming it's principally about the
outflow of information to generate
dreams and in fact the chemical profile
is oppositional to input which is about
saving so it's about sort of pumping out
information rather than committing
information and so when you come out of
a dream sleep you still get this sort of
lingering after sort of taste of
chemistry as it were in the brain that
means that the dreaming brain is more
programmed to be outputting a narrative
and an experience rather than naturally
committing it to memory which is the
opposite direction if that makes sense
it does make sense how where are you of
dimethyltryptamine I'm somewhere aware
of it scientifically not not not
personally initially yeah yeah one of
the things about the psychedelic
experiences with dimethyltryptamine
first of all it's endogenous your brain
produces it your lungs or liver produce
it but when you have a DMT experience
after it's over the memory fades very
rapidly and it seems just like a dream
in that regard where while while you're
having it what's bizarre is that you're
having it while you're awake yeah and
then after you have it within 10 20
minutes it is just like a dream that you
can't remember I remember like little
flashes of experiences that I've had and
there's been a lot of speculation that
that's one of the things that you're
experiencing while you're in heavy REM
sleep and that could be responsible for
the crazy visuals that you have that
seems so vivid I mean there there's been
times where I've had dreams where I was
a hundred percent convinced that I was
awake yeah and then something happened
like I do this thing sometimes where
I'll if I do it consciously a lot I
think I saw in one of those wacky movies
like what the bleep to me no I think I
saw it in that well you walk up to a
door as you're walking through the door
you knock on the side of the door and go
am i awake nope not awake or am i asleep
rather you
no I'm not asleep because I'm not going
to the door well I did that and my hand
was like going right through the wall Oh
sleeping and then I woke up and I was
like but the feeling that I had while I
was in that dream it was so vivid I mean
everything seemed so real like what
could possibly be causing me to
construct this artificial reality in my
mind that at the moment at least was
indistinguishable from the reality that
I experience right now and I'm assuming
because I just knocked on this table
that I'm awake
yeah I really hope I'm not just a
effective character in your dreams maybe
we're sharing a dream
yeah very inception like possible not
based on the science so far but I think
you know what you're speaking about
there really is almost why would why
would mother nature create this thing
called the dream experience you know
what would be the function of
essentially every night going into what
sums up to be about two total hours of
virtual reality experience and testing
one possibility which is deeply
unsatisfying is that it's just a
byproduct it's just epi phenomenal that
when your brain goes into this thing
called REM sleep and all of the
different patterns of brain activity
that we described an offshoot is this
thing that we call dreaming in the same
way that a light bulb the reason that we
construct the apparatus that's a light
bulb is to produce light but when you
produce light in that way you also
produce heat it was never the function
of the light bulb it's just what happens
when you produce light in that way maybe
dreaming is just sort of the heat of REM
sleep and REM sleep serves lots of other
functions but that doesn't feel to me
right though mmm why well firstly I
think it's probably additionally
metabolically demanding to have dreams
in addition to this thing called REM
sleep and whenever Mother Nature burns
calories it's usually for a reason
because they're so precious hmm that's a
good point that makes sense too yeah I
read some article about the
lack of REM sleep with marijuana users
and it was trying to say and it made me
super skeptical even as a pot smoker it
was trying to say that it's not bad for
you because what's essentially doing is
bypassing the REM sleep and going
directly into the deep sleep and then
it's helping you in that regard does
that make sense to you it doesn't make
sense as a neuroscientist he says nay
you [ __ ] stoners I'm sorry I'm so
deeply unpopular you know I'm telling
you know you know don't smoke pot stay
away from alcohol you know apart from a
general personality which is dislikable
this doesn't help me you're definitely
not decidable but I don't think you're
saying anything wrong I think I think
marijuana like most things is best used
in moderation and one thing that I got
out of the sober October thing wasn't
just that it's fascinating to see the
dreams like just ramped up and get crazy
but also that when you take a few days
off and then smoke a little pot the pot
actually has more of an impact in fact
one of my favorite psychedelic authors
and lectures the late great Terence
Mckenna his advice was to not do
marijuana for long periods of time and
then do as much as you could stand and
he was a you know a real psychedelic
adventurer and his thought was that to
really get the benefit out of marijuana
it's not something that should be used
daily and reck really recreationally it
should be used as a psychedelic
sacrament not should because he actually
did smoke pot pretty rarely pretty
regularly rather but his thought was you
really want to get the full impact of it
you shouldn't be accustomed to it and
when you're accustomed to it you build
up a tolerance to it and doesn't have
the same impact like it's that thing I
don't know if you've ever been around
pot smokers but when someone doesn't
smoke pot and then they get talked into
smoking pot with some pot smokers it's
always a terrible idea you got a bunch
of people with super high tolerances and
some poor person that doesn't have any
tolerance and they just they just get
taken down a tornado rabbit hole journey
into their chancellor at 16
is so paranoid and thinking about
everything freaking out all these
sensations that they're just never
experienced before but uh the the idea
that you could bypass REM sleep and go
straight into the deep sleep that
doesn't make any sense to you no it
doesn't and what we've learned over the
past at a 30 or 40 years is all stages
of sleep are important hmm you know when
you think about sleep as a state it
makes no sense
you know firstly you're vulnerable to
predation you're not finding food you're
not finding a mate you're not
reproducing you're not caring for your
young on any one of those grounds sleep
should be strongly selected against as a
collective I mean it's it's almost
idiotic
if sleep does not serve an absolutely
vital function it is the biggest mistake
that the evolutionary process ever made
hmm and that counts for all of the
stages of sleep - again mother nature
wouldn't waste time putting you into a
state that wasn't necessary and what
we've discovered is that all of those
different stages of sleep that we spoke
about all have unique and separate
functions so you can't shortchange any
one of them you don't need to bias
towards one and try and sort of you know
placate the other you know evolutionist
has taken a long time to get the
blueprint accurately correct for each
physiological individual I wouldn't play
around with it and think you're smarter
than that process when I read it I felt
like it was a justification for smoking
a lot of pot like man you're just
getting deeper sleep man you don't need
that REM sleep you're passing it up man
you just go right into the deep heavy
necessary sleep o contra contrary
potheads so what is happening to the
body during REM sleep that's so critical
that one particular aspect of sleep so
firstly in the body the your
cardiovascular system seems to do
something quite strange
it goes through periods of dramatic
acceleration and then dramatic
deceleration during mind yet during REM
sleep quite unpredictable - we also know
that during REM sleep you
brain paralyzes your body so that your
mind can dream safely so Wow I mean and
that makes a lot of you know sense if
you're thinking that you're you know
this world champion mixed martial arts
person and it's in the middle of the
night you're not it's dark you can't see
you're not perceiving your outside world
you're going to get popped out of the
gene pool very quickly if you start
acting out that experience so there is a
barrier in place that mother nature
locks you down in incarceration muscling
car car serration that's crazy that you
say there because when I was fighting
when I was young I would wake up
throwing kicks I would kick in the
middle of the night I would do it all
the time
I'd be sleeping and I just I would move
and throw a kick in the middle of the
night you know I remember it waking me
up like what the [ __ ] is wrong with me
and then I try to go back to sleep again
but I was obviously dreaming about
competing do you actually remember the
sir when you woke up
did you remember dreaming at that point
or did you just have no recollection of
anything going on at that point I I
believe I had a recollection it's been a
long time but I believe I had a
recollection like I would be like in bed
with my girlfriend and I'd wake her up
too you know because I just told like I
wouldn't throw a full kick but my body
would move like I was going to you know
like I would turn my hips and my leg
would extend it was my body was it was I
to the the idea that it's so extreme
like the activity of fighting is so
extreme that my brain had kind of like
hyper-charged itself to compete at this
very high level you know and that this
was like so unusual that it was it was
almost that red alert all the time and
maybe even trying to work out patterns
yeah while I was sleeping
that's exactly the evidence that we have
now so for things like motor skills or
even rats running around a maze where
they will learn specific sort of you
know navigational pathways and even
skilled motor movements what you can do
is you can place these electrodes in two
senses of the of the brain we we work in
my sleep sleep center works on humans
but
other people have done these studies in
rats and you implant electrodes and you
measure the brain cells firing as the
rat is running around the maze and let's
say that you can sort of play little
tones for each brain cell so they're
running around the maze and and you can
listen to the brain cells learning the
signature of that maze so it goes but
but but bum bum bum bum what was amazing
is that when you let those rats sleep
but you keep listening to the brain what
you hear is as if the brain is actually
and in fact it is it's replaying the
exact same sequence they memory sequence
that it was learning whilst it was awake
its replaying but at a speed that is 20
times faster Wow so you know now we
start to get into this Inception world
and I don't mean to because the
scientific data it really that we're not
sort of in that territory but you know
that notion of time compression and time
dilation that Christopher Nolan played
so well within that movie we can see
that at the level of brain cell firing
in rats as they're learning these mazes
and it comes back to what you're saying
which is that the better that they
rehearse those skilled memories when you
wake them up and test them the next day
that predicts how much better they are
in terms of their performance so it's
not just that you learn you go to sleep
and you replay and you hit the Save
button on these new memories you
actually sculpt out those memories and
you improve them and we've done studies
with motor skill learning critical for
athletic performance and practice does
not make perfect practice with a night
of sleep is what makes perfect because
you come back the next day and you're 20
to 30% better in terms of you're skilled
performance than where you were at the
end of your practice session the day
before Wow I mean sleep is the greatest
legal performance-enhancing drug that
most people are probably neglecting in
sport Wow and not just for your physical
performance but actually skill learning
that's right skill learning memory and
then also you know downstairs in the
body all over the recuperative benefits
and you can flip the coin by the way if
you're getting six hours of sleep or
less your time to fizz
exhaustion drops by up to 30%
so you could spend all of your time
training for a 10-round fight perfect
condition but then I put you on six
hours of sleep the night before you're
now gonna be physically exhausted by
round seven rather than round ten Wow
but well that's a really hard thing for
fighter because they have a very
difficult time sleeping the night before
a big fight yeah it's very very
difficult cuz usually pretty and yep and
I would imagine it's got to be I mean
it's probably got to take a huge toll
and is probably a huge benefit if they
can somehow or another bypass all that
and just relax and learn how to relax
and learn how to actually sleep I mean
it's I think you know it's one of what
constantly trying to hack the
physiological system especially in elite
sports these days because you know small
fractions of a percent of gain can make
a huge difference well that sounds like
36 a monster huge yeah I mean your time
to get if not just physically exhausting
but you know the lactic acid builds up
quicker the less and less that you sleep
your ability of the lungs to actually
expire carbon dioxide and inhale oxygen
decreases the less sleep that you have
that makes so much sense Wow cuz when I
was doing I was doing fear factor and I
was doing stand-up comedy and then I was
also doing another television show and I
was doing jujitsu I was never got a
two-hour sleep I mostly got for usually
got four and my cardio always sucked
yeah who is terrible and I'd be like why
is my cardio suck I workout so much like
that was probably what it was yeah it's
a huge pot now how many hours of sleep
should you get somewhere between
excuse me somewhere between 7 to 9 hours
once you get below 7 hours of sleep we
can measure objective impairments in
your brain in your body I can show that
in the last two days and I can share it
show it because I basically did the same
workout two days in a row the day before
I had flown back from Boston very tired
hang out with my kids all day went to
get some sleep but then I had to do some
stuff at like two o'clock in the morning
and I just never really got good sleep
and then my youngest daughter got up at
5:00 she was crying
then eventually my alarm went off at
8:00 so my my sleep was like 3-4 hours
it was all screwy and the night before I
was even less because I had flown and I
had to get up early for the flight and I
tried to sleep on the plane and I went
running and I felt like dogs shed yeah
and then during the day I felt like dog
[ __ ] I just didn't have like as I was
running I just didn't have any extra
gear I was like I did it I pushed
through it but then it was over I was
like oh well last night last night I
slept seven and a half hours woke up
today lifted weights ran ran felt great
feel great now like two days in
difference I mean that's the difference
the difference is one day I got real
sleep one day I didn't I did the exact
same thing even more today I did I
lifted weights today as well and I just
feel great so I could see I could see it
physiologically in the difference in my
performance in 24 hours
yeah and that's noticeable I mean we see
that too you know you're your peak
muscle strength your physical vertical
jump height and your peak running speed
all of those things correlate with sleep
the less that you have the worse those
outcomes are probably one of the most
surprising factors there was injury risk
when they've looked at athletes across a
season and they've just plotted you know
how frequently will they get injured and
then they surveyed them you know how
much sleep were you getting and they
bucketed them into sort of people who
are getting nine hours 7 hours 6 5 4 and
it's a perfect linear relationship the
less sleep that you have higher your
injury risk so people getting 9 hours
versus 5 hours there was almost a 60%
increase in probability of injury risk
during a season do you attribute that to
exhaustion or do you tribute that to a
lack of recovery from the previous
night's workout is it a combination of
those things
is it exhaustion causing you to misstep
perhaps and like twist an ankle or to
turn a knee yeah it's all of those
things all those I mean even if you look
at micro balance if you look at sort of
these stability muscles versus you know
major muscles those stability muscles
also fail when you're not getting
sufficient sleep and I think we often
underestimate how critical they are in
sport performance particularly in terms
of combating and placating in
risk to so if you just get someone on a
stability ball you know I'm sort of just
dosed them down with sleep eight hours
five hours you know three hours and just
notice how those stability muscles help
you balance just the basic active
balance that deteriorates dramatically
no wonder you're getting more injury
risk totally makes sense now as a
neuroscientist what do you attribute
when when people talk about
visualization and visualization is it's
a huge factor in improving technical
skills specifically martial arts which
is a big fan of obviously martial arts
when you you visualize people who
visualize who sit down and like go over
their body going through the motions and
doing things though those people perform
better they inform better they they they
learn quicker what do you attribute that
to do you think it's the same thing as
what's happening when you're sleeping
just maybe to a lesser extent I think
it's to a lesser extent but people have
done those studies where they've looked
at sort of whether you actually
physically practice let's say on a
keyboard just because it's easier to
sort of manage in a laboratory versus
just imagining sort of typing out that
sequence and just the act of physical
visualization of sort of imagination of
that motor skill it's it's about 50% as
effective as physically performing it -
and it's 50% is effective what I mean
there is in changing the plastic
connections within the brain so even
just visualization you know passive play
as it were still can actually cause a
rewiring of the brain beneficially Wow
you know learning techniques
specifically martial arts techniques my
good friend Eddie Bravo is a
world-famous jujitsu instructor he's
he's always comparing it to tying your
shoe and he said do you know how like
when you were a little kid and you're
trying to figure out how to tie your
shoe it's a extremely difficult thing to
do you know like how do I do this and
you put that down and do loops like I'm
watching my seven-year-old
go through that right now but now as a
grown man when I tie my shoe I could
just be talking you know what oh yeah
we're gonna go tomorrow and I'll doing
it I don't even know what I did if you
tried to ask me to explain how I tie my
shoe I'd be like how do I like I don't
even know how I do it because it's just
I have it in there yes it's just and the
idea with martial arts is you've got to
be eat all of your techniques have to be
automatic someone extends the arm you
instantly hook it and go into the armbar
you know it's someone you you have to
have these paths like so drilled in that
you don't even know you're doing them
until it's over yeah so automaticity is
one of the things that sleep actually
accomplishes here I was talking about
those 20 to 30% benefits in motor school
performance so we did some additional
studies to actually say well what how
how does sleep do that you know where in
your skill performance to sleep give you
the benefit so you're right tying a
shoelace you know even driving a car
with stick you know at first it's just
overwhelming it's so difficult to clutch
its gas pedal you know it's gig and now
it's just second nature you know it's
shifted from conscious to automatic from
conscious and unconscious if you look at
performance that is conscious and not
automatic it's usually very staccato
it's this then it's that then it's that
it's not fluid if you heard someone
trying to sort of play piano to begin
with doesn't sound very fluid you know
as someone who is a maestro it just
flows out of them so we looked at this
with motor skill performance again sort
of like keyboard playing musicianship
and you learning you learning you get
better and let's say that you type a
sequence let's say four one three to
four and people learn it but they have
these problem points throughout the
sequence they have four one three two
four four one three to four as if it's
there's a sticking point it's the same
thing with any skilled performance in
athletics and it's the brain
chunking things up a very long motor
sequence gets chunked up into small sort
of digestible bites it's a good way to
begin learning but it's not a way to
create automaticity at some point what
you have to do is stitch all of those
things together and
just flows like a sentence like a
sentence yeah like a piano piece like
you know a sequence of movements if
you've got you know in martial arts
you've got you know yeah so what we
found was that before sleep you've got
these big problem points these gaps in
your motor skill learning sleep does not
necessarily improve the places where
you're already good sleep is intelligent
it goes in finds that problem point that
friction point in your motor skill sort
of deficit and it smoothes it out so you
come back the next day and now it's just
4 1 3 2 4 4 and 3 2 4 4
it's automaticity and it's exactly what
you're describing you know speak to
musicians they'll say I was playing I
just couldn't get that piece the night
before and then it came back the next
day and I sat down and I could just play
sleeps doing its work
I've heard that too with problems and
that's why people say sleep on it yeah
yeah you've never been told to stay
awake on a problem sometimes when you're
about to go to bed it's almost
overwhelming you just can't concentrate
on anything else but this problem
whatever it is and then you go to sleep
and you wake up in the morning like it's
alright yeah it's gonna be fine
yeah I got it I know what to do and
sleeps at it you know and there's lots
of anecdotal evidence of sleep inspired
creativity and now the shifts too one of
the benefits of dreaming in fact it's
during dream sleep when we take all of
the information that we've previously
learned and we start to collide it with
all of the new information that we've
learned it's it's a little bit like
group therapy for memories you know
everyone gets a name badge and you all
get to speak to each other and the brain
starts to seek out and test novel
connections and new associations so it's
almost like informational alchemy and
you wake up the next morning with a
revised mind wide web that is now
capable of divining you know incredible
solutions to previously impenetrable
problems and lots of anecdotes you know
dmitri mendeleev came up with a periodic
table of elements by way of dream
inspired insight you know talk about a
Herculean task take all of the elements
in
the known universe and figure out a
structure as to how they all fit
together off you go
his waking brain could not do it his
sleeping brain solved the problem
Einstein by the way if this is great
Einstein was suggested to be a short
sleeper and we don't know if that's true
but even if he was he was a habitual
NAPA during the day I've got some great
pictures of him on his workbench and he
used sleep ruthlessly as a tool for
creativity and he would sit at his desk
and he would have a sort of pad of paper
and a pencil and he had her a chair with
arm rests and he would pick up two steel
ball bearings and take a metal saucepan
and turn it upside down place it
underneath the arm of the chair and put
the tool Stiebel steel ball bearings in
his hand then he would rest back and he
would start to fall asleep and so he
didn't fall too far into sleep what
would happen is at some point his muscle
tone would relax they would release the
steel ball bearings they would crash on
the saucepan wake him up and then he
would write down all of the creative
ideas that he was her isn't that
brilliant
so no wonder yet you're never told to
sort of stay awake in a problem and in
every language that I've been quiet
about today
French Swahili that phrase sleeping on a
problem seems to exist which must mean
that this benefit of dream sleep
transcends cultural boundaries
I should note I think it's important
that the French the French translation
is much closer to you you sleep with a
problem.we the British you say you sleep
on a problem the French you say you
sleep with a problem I think it says so
much about the romantic difference
between the British and the French you
know they're the French is trying to
[ __ ] everything [ __ ] their problems I
lose my British passport passaic that's
just a joke that's fascinating that
Einstein figured that out too that he
literally had like a whole routine
and that he would drop this ball would
hit it bang and wake up and start
writing like saluting oh he loves to be
in the room watching Einstein - that
must've been fascinating oh sorry I said
I'd say it's Edison my goodness I'm an
idiot at
oh sorry changes everything that's
problem that wasn't Edison a thief
though didn't he steal everything from
Tesla
I think this made but I mean he has a
lot to answer for by the way in terms of
the way that we're sleeping you know he
Electra he was the first person to
electrify society not necessarily create
the the light bulb but he really you
know gave shifted us from a point where
now we controlled the night in terms of
illumination and like we are a dark
deprived society in this modern era and
that's one of the things that are
keeping us awake at night a lack of
darkness yeah not just that but also our
inability to see the stars anymore the
light pollution that we have at night I
think it's I think it's a giant shift in
perspective like have you ever been to a
planetarium or an observatory like one
of those yeah at night there's a Keck
Observatory in Hawaii's place I try to
go to every year and it's it's really
stunning because it's very high up
I think the observatory is it's somewhat
it's somewhere more than nine thousand
feet above sea level and then I think
you go even further and then they have
the telescopes but you got a visitor
center and you go to the visitor center
they have some telescopes set up but
it's you actually drive through the
clouds
so as you're driving up this mountain we
were bummed out were like oh it's cloudy
we might not be able to see anything and
then you drive through the clouds and
then when you get through the clouds you
like holy [ __ ] and you feel like you're
on a spaceship flying through space and
this is what our ancestors saw every
night when they went to sleep with a
clear sky they saw all the stars they
saw the full Milky Way like this and the
way the Big Island has set up they use
diffuse lighting all over the island
because of the Keck Observatory so you
don't have the same level of light
pollution that you have when you're in a
normal city like Los Angeles which is
terrible I mean LA if you look up you
see like 1 or 2 stars because
everything's lit up it's crazy bright
that I think that perspective is that's
a giant factor in the way human beings
look at their relationship with the
universe but I think that also just the
light everywhere constant light
everywhere that's got to be a big fact
why people sleeps a little right we know
it is now I mean these studies have been
done you know the first part is the
external light which is you know street
lighting you know even if you've got
curtains that can still bleed through
yeah
but then when you come into the home you
know the invasion of light into the home
by way of Technology has been a big
problem people looking at their phones
before they go to vote well first the
yeah I mean the incandescent light bulb
sort of was the start of it and light
bulbs can suppress a hormone that's
called melatonin it's the hormone of
darkness and it tells your brain when
it's dark and when it's time to sleep
but then you add into that screen usage
and they've done studies were for
example you know one hour of iPad
reading versus just one hour of reading
on a book you know in dim light that one
hour of iPad reading firstly delayed the
release of this critical darkness
hormone called melatonin by about three
hours so if you read on your iPad for an
hour here in California your melatonin
peak is not going to arrive and it's
somewhere in Hawaii time in fact it's
three hours delayed it's 50% less in
terms of its peak and furthermore you
don't get the same amount of REM sleep
and when you wake up the next morning
you don't feel as refreshed or restored
by your sleep those studies have been
done - Wow what should someone do if
they have a hard time sleeping like say
if you're a person whose insomnia you
have a hard time getting getting to bed
you have a hard time staying asleep when
you wake up you can't go back to bed
yeah there are there strategies there
are I mean I think for most people there
are five things that you can do just out
the gate to get better sleep regularity
is probably the most important thing I
can tell you go to bed at the same time
wake up at the same time no matter
whether it's the weekend weekday
regularity is key we've spoken about
light for example when you in the last
hour before bed try to stay away from
screens but also just switch off half
the lights in the house you would be
surprised at how sup errific that is it
really starts to sort of make you feel a
bit more drowsy they've done some great
studies where they would take people out
you know into the Rockies no electric
light no electricity whatsoever
and they started to go to bed two hours
earlier than the acclaimed natural
bedtime wasn't just because they didn't
have anything necessarily to do it was
that their melatonin was rising you know
two hours earlier so keep it dark
the third is probably keep it cool your
brain actually needs to drop its
temperature by about two to three
degrees Fahrenheit to initiate sleep hmm
and that's the reason that you will
always find it easier to fall asleep in
a room that's too cold than too hot I've
seen people use cold pads yeah she knows
you sleep on these cold pads were
younger those yeah I mean their evidence
is pretty good that cooling the body
actually works they've you know in the
book I write about a series of studies
where they had people in it's almost
like a wetsuit but it has all of these
veins running through it and they could
actually perfuse warm or cold water into
any part of the body hands core of the
body feet and so that you could
exquisitely manipulate the temperature
of any part of the body and what they
found is that they could effectively
cool the body down and it
instantaneously made people fall asleep
faster and it gave them deeper deep non
REM sleep that sort of restorative sleep
for the body so and you can even look at
studies where people sleep semi-naked
and that also seems to improve their
sleep and they get a little bit more
deep sleep too so cold is better the
paradox here though is that you need to
warm your feet and your hands to kind of
charm the blood away from your core out
to the surface and radiate that heat
really so you should go to sleep with
socks and gloves on yeah or better still
have a hot bath the evidence here too
that I discuss where people say you know
I get out of a hot bath I feel nice and
toasty and relaxed and that's why I fall
asleep it's the opposite when you get
into a bath you get vasodilation all
that you sort of get rosy cheeks red
skin all of the blood rushes to the
surface you get out of the bath and you
have this massive thermal dump of heat
just evacuates from the body your core
body temperature plummets and that's why
you sleep better so you can hack the
system very easily Wow so your core body
temperature plummets and that's what
makes you sleep easier
yeah that sounds so counterintuitive
yeah but it makes sense and it makes
sense because that's how we would design
if you look at hunter-gatherer tribes
whose way of life has not changed for
thousands of years and you ask how do
they sleep one of the things that seems
to dictate their sleep is the rise and
fall of temperature
you know temperature is its lowest in
the deep in the deer of the night you
know three or four in the morning and as
that temperature that climate
temperature starts to drop that's when
they start to get drowsy as if
temperature is just sort of signaling to
the brain now it's time to sleep so
light as well as temperature are two key
triggers to help you get better sleep if
you look at those tribes by the way and
when they go to sleep and they wake up
you know they go to sleep probably at
two hours after dusk sort of 8:00 to
9:00 in the evening wake up about half
an hour even an hour before dawn it's
the rise in temperature rather than
light that triggers their awakening but
there's a reason you know have you ever
thought about what the term midnight
actually means middle of the night and
that's what it should be for all of us
but in modernity we've been dislocated
from our natural rhythms and now
midnight has become the time when we
think I should check Facebook last time
you know I should send my lies to email
yeah that wasn't that is not how we were
you know designed to sleep and in fact
we may also be designed to sleep by
physically too if you look at those
hunter-gatherers they don't sleep one
long bout of eight hours at night yeah
I've heard this recently that people
that you should have to sleeps the idea
of two sleeps
yeah it's actually a little different
than the idea of to sleep so there was a
time in sort of the Dickensian era where
people would sleep for the first half of
the night maybe sort of for hours or so
then they would wake up they would
socialize they would eat they would
marry love and then they would go back
and have a second sleep
if you look at natural biological
rhythms in the brain and the body that
doesn't really seem to be how we were
designed it certainly seems to be
something that we did in society but I
think it's more of a societal trend than
it was a biological edict however we do
seem to have two sleep periods the way
that we were designed those tribes will
often sleep about six and a half hours
seven hours of sleep at night and then
especially in the summer they'll have
that siesta like behavior in the
afternoon and all of us have that sort
of this what's called the post prandial
dip in alertness just means after lunch
and if I measure your brainwave activity
with electrodes I can see a drop in your
physiological alertness somewhere
between 2 to 4 p.m. in the afternoon but
is that dependent on diet it's not
people think it is you know especially
after they've had a heavy lunch yeah you
can actually just have people fast in
sort of well fasting for long periods of
time actually makes you sleep much worse
but you can have people abstain from
lunch and you still get that drop so
it's independent of food it's a
genetically hardwired pre-programmed
drop that suggests we should be sleeping
by physically but does is that dependent
upon their standard diet because if if
someone is on a carbohydrate
carbohydrate rich diet a lot of times
you do get that spike yeah then you
crash crash but when people are on
low-carb and high fat diets they don't
get that and they they tend to be more
even with their energy through the day
yeah so yeah that sort of more constant
release of energy can actually help you
sort of almost combat that low but that
low exists no matter what exactly so
even if you don't think it exists it's
there it's still present interesting so
why did they do that and then the the
Dickens error why did they but what is
there a root cause of their double sleep
thing we don't know I mean it's hard to
sort of really go fascinating yeah it's
a new crack was a trend yeah that it was
a movement did they would just wake up
and do things and yeah it was because
they didn't have TV sounds like they did
some pretty interesting switch to a nice
but yeah yeah well they created a lot of
art then to write a lot of writing and a
lot of fascinating stuff came out at
that time now when you're
when you're measuring people's health
and when you're measuring people's
health in regard to how much sleep they
have like what how do you how do you do
that do you just talk to people do you
do surveys like how do you get like a
detailed analysis of people's patterns
so you can do it at many different
levels I mean we can start at the sort
of gross high level which is
epidemiological studies across millions
of people where you do surveys you ask
them about their sleep and then you look
at health outcomes
the first thing from that data that's
clear is an unfortunate truth the
shorter your sleep the shorter your life
well short sleep predicts all cause
mortality which is really ironic because
people that want to sleep less I like
you know I don't have a whole lot of
time you know this life is short yes
[ __ ] shorter if you sleep less yeah
that's that old maxim you know you can
sleep when you're dead
yeah well it's mortally unwise advice
because we know from the data you will
be both dead sooner and the quality of
that now shorter life will be
significantly worse
yeah that's counterintuitive to people
the idea that you need this it's not
just like you're making best use of time
by sleeping less you're not you you
would make best use of time by being
awake less exactly which is crazy
I mean wakefulness firstly from a brain
perspective is a low-level brain damage
we know that wakefulness is yeah low
like right now we're you and I are
getting low-level brain damage yep
that's right
and it's sleep that offers a repair a
tree function Wow and you know I'll give
you one example which is your risk for
Alzheimer's disease insufficient sleep
across the lifespan now seems to be one
of the most significant lifestyle
factors determining whether or not
you'll develop Alzheimer's what studies
or if any have been done on people that
work the third shift
so people have looked at shift work in
general they haven't necessarily split
it down to that granular point but what
we see is that shift workers have higher
rates of obesity high rates of diabetes
but perhaps most frightening Lee cancer
and in fact we now know the link between
a lack of sleep and cancer is quite
strong insufficient sleep is linked to
cancer of the bowel cancer of the
prostate cancer of the breast and the
association
has become so powerful that recently the
World Health Organization decided to
classify any form of nighttime shift
work as a probable carcinogen whoa yeah
so jobs that may induce cancer because
of a disruption of your sleep wake
rhythms
are there other correlating factors like
don't people that sleep less or work
into the night don't they eat more and
eat more shitty food they do both of
those things yeah and we know exactly
the pathway so there are two hormones
that control your appetite and your
weight and one is called leptin the
other is called ghrelin they sound like
hobbits but they're not the real home
the real chemical leptin is the chemical
that tells your brain your full your
satiated you don't want to eat anymore
ghrelin does the opposite it's the
hunger hormone it says you want to eat
more you're not satisfied with your food
if I take people and these studies have
been done we've done some of these
studies too and you just put you a group
of healthy people on four or five hours
of sleep for let's say one week and you
look at those two hormones they go and
in fortunately opposite directions so
leptin that says you're full stop eating
that gets suppressed by a lack of sleep
ghrelin the hunger hormone that gets
ramped up so firstly people who are
sleeping just 5 to 6 hours a night will
on average eat somewhere between 200 to
300 extra calories each day because of
the underslept state add that up it's
about 70 thousand extra calories a year
it's about 10 to 15 pounds of obese mass
each year which for me is starting to
sound familiar but what we also know is
that it's not just that when you're
underslept
you eat more you eat more of the wrong
things hmm so if and this the great
scientific work if you give people this
sort of finger buffet and they can eat
whatever they want and it contains all
of the different food groups and you
sleep deprived them or you give them a
full eight hours of sleep yes they start
to overeat by somewhere around about 450
calories with total sleep deprivation
but what they go after is heavy
in carbohydrates and simple sugars
processed food and they stay away from
the healthy sort of leafy greens nuts
proteins etc hmm so you're not just
eating more you're eating more of the
wrong things and that's why a lack of
sleep has such a strong obesogenic
profile to it and you can take a step
back - and you say well if you look at
the rise of obesity over the past 70
years it's just this upward exponential
increase and if you plot on the same
graph the amount of sleep that society
is getting it goes in the opposite
direction as sleep time has declined
obesity rates have increased I'm not
going to sit here and tell you that the
obesity epidemic is simply a sleep
problem it's not it's a problem of us
being sedentary processed foods larger
food serving sizes if you take those
factors though by themselves they cannot
explain the increase in obesity other
things are at play is sleep one of them
now we know it is it's a critical factor
in the obesogenic epidemic I know from
personal experience when I'm tired I
always gravitate towards the worst
choices it's it for me it's late-night
cheeseburgers yeah you know Wendy's at
two o'clock in the morning or whatever
what happens if you get naps like say if
you only have five hours of sleep but
you take a two-hour nap during the day
does everything make up yes and no so
what you're talking about there is what
we call prophylactic napping which is
sort of strategically trying to help
combat your deficiency of sleep naps can
actually give you benefits we've done
some of these studies were they improve
you know your learning your memory your
alertness your concentration
especially your emotional regulation -
sleep is critical for emotional
first-aid and mental health however you
can't keep using naps to self-medicate
sort of short sleep of you know four or
five hours each night we know that the
system itself your your brain has no
capacity to regain all of the sleep that
it's lost it will try to sleep back some
of that debt but what we've discovered
let's say I take you tonight I deprive
you of sleep eight hours lost then I
give you all
of the recovery sleep but you want on a
second third or fourth night you will
sleep longer but you will only get back
maybe just three or four hours of that
lost total eight hmm so sleep is not
like the bank
you can't accumulate a debt and then
hope to pay it off at the weekend and so
there is no credit system within the
brain for sleep you can't bank it which
is odd by the way I would love that
system do you know then you would know
what you're owed you would know what you
out but I could also just know when I'm
going into a state of you know sleep
debt and I could build up some credit
and there's precedent for this by the
way there is a system like that in the
brain it's called the fat cell because
there were times during our evolutionary
past where we faced famine and we faced
feast and so the body learned to adapt
to that and said when you have feast
store it up as caloric energy in these
things called adipose cells fat cells
and then when you go into famine you can
spend that caloric credit where is that
in the brain why don't we have that the
reason is very simple human beings are
the only species that deliberately
deprive themselves of sleep for no
apparent reason
in other words Mother Nature has never
faced the challenge of coming up with a
safety net for a lack of sleep we've
never been forced to come up with that
solution that's why we get such
demonstrable disease sickness and
impairment when you undergo a lack of
sleep so this is a recent occurrence and
in human beings is that we're saying
yeah I mean the the only time we see it
in nature is when you go into conditions
of starvation the only way that you can
get a species to sleep less and it's
very very difficult to do because sleep
is just so essential is when you put
them under conditions of extreme
starvation there they will forego some
sleep to stay awake so that they forage
in a larger sort of circumference area
to try and find more food it's probably
the reason that when people go into
fasting their sleep is so terrible
because the brain is receiving this
ancient trigger that you're going
without food you're in a state of
starvation you need to stay awake and
hunt for
food that's why your sleep gets so much
worse when you're when you're indicating
fasting that's fascinating I did not
know that so fasting is when you're
talking about multiple day fasting and
not intermittent fasting we don't know
the evidence for intermittent fasting so
you know if you're some people are doing
sort of 12 hours 14 hours 16 hours there
that doesn't seem to be extreme enough
to trigger a change in sleep but if you
fast for these long periods you know two
days three days four days you can really
see some quite marked sleep
fragmentation sleep is there you don't
ask any of those people they'll tell you
that's fascinating because people always
cite the health benefits of multiple day
fasts do you think that that's just like
a placebo effect I mean certainly we
know that there are chemical pathways
that when you go into fasting are
activated that seem to be beneficial for
health outcomes and if there's a big
literature on sort of fasting and aging
with the mTOR pathway for example but
you know we also know that as a species
were we were not designed to have such
terrible fragmented sleep and we spoke
about how sleep regulates your appetite
you know if you're trying not to eat
food and sort of control and manage your
weight the last thing that you probably
want to do is be shortchanging yourself
on sleep because it's only going to make
you even more hungry and reach for sort
of worse food so I still think there's
room for fasting in the equation but I
think those extreme fasts you know and
the havoc that it plays on sleep it's
still yet to be understood you've got to
be very careful with playing around with
and I think going beyond sensible you
know behavior so what does it like what
is if you say if you're gonna fast for
two days what switch is on that forces
your your body into this haphazard sleep
program so that's where that hormone
ghrelin just kicks into high gear that
hormone that is just saying I
it's a starvation hormone at that point
it's not just the hunger hormone you've
gone over into starvation and that will
promote our alertness it promotes
chemicals that try to keep you away
chemicals like dopamine to sort of you
know force you wide awake so it's
forcing you to go hunt or gather that's
right yeah
and this is even if your body goes into
a state of ketosis that we don't know
people have not tried to correlate sort
of you know the profile change in
ketosis versus alterations in sleep I
actually think it would be fascinating
you know maybe there's a there's a peak
where it's bad and then you sort of you
crest it and then things get better you
know does the body acclimate to that I
don't know it's we've never seen the
body being able to sort of re-engage
with you know cognitive function with a
dose of sleep deprivation that keeps
going so if I and these studies have
been done take people and give them two
weeks of seven hours of sleep five hours
of sleep three hours of sleep or no
sleep you know even by sort of seven
days or even 14 days of six hours of
sleep your cognitive performance just
nosedives like a dart into the ground
and it doesn't show any signs of
leveling off as if there is no asymptote
that it could keep going and by the way
people should know that after 20 hours
of being awake you are as impaired
cognitively as you would be if you were
legally drunk Wow what about physical
movement same thing yeah in terms if
you're yeah alertness and reaction time
but it's worse and this is where you
know drowsy driving comes in for every
30 seconds that we've been speaking
there has been a car accident linked to
sleeplessness drowsiness seems kills
more people on the roads than either
alcohol or drugs combined well why are
why are drowsy driving accidents so
deathly well no I'm not endorsing those
other things of course not but let's
just think about why that's the case
when you're underslept
you start to have what are called
microsleeps sometimes your eyelid does
not close all the way it just partially
closes but the brain essentially goes to
sleep for just a very brief period of
time you can even see individual brain
cells
looks like they go to sleep during these
micro sleeps at that moment if you're
traveling in a vehicle on the freeway
you've got a one-ton missile traveling
at 65 miles an hour and no one is in
control one ton of you're lucky yeah
yeah last time you saw it too
Town Car unless you have a Miata yeah
yeah or ya know McLaren p1 but you know
if you are even those are everything
are they really yeah she was my lack of
knowledge despite living them but you
know I think and what happens here is
that when with drugs and alcohol
it's often the case of a problem of
later reaction mmm with with a lack of
sleep it's a problem of no reaction at
all so you're out of it so you're out of
it so rather than breaking too late
there's just no braking whatsoever they
have my tip for people to if you you you
find yourself cold or tired and driving
and you have to stay awake take either
ice or ice cold water and put it in a
washcloth and then rub your face with it
it keeps your way looks yeah it works I
mean if you're forced to drive for
whatever reason you have to you know you
have 20 minutes to go and you're really
exhausted do that is is the best take a
like a wet cloth put ice inside of it
and just rub your face it just wakes you
right up for whatever reason and it's I
mean those the statistics around rise
drowsy driving though you know a
frightening and it's a weird thing when
you're on the road you're there's
something about those white lines that
just want to put you to sleep there's no
other time or I feel more compelled to
just conk out while I'm awake yeah it's
probably one of the greatest sedatives
known to man you know if that monotonous
you know behavior and the longer you go
with that monotony the worse things get
you know and if you look at you know
teenagers that's where we see some of
the greatest impact of shruti driving
you know it's the leading cause of death
in most first world nations suicide a
second wow that is crazy speaks this you
know in this model of later school start
times they've done these studies there
was a great one that was done I think in
Teton County in Wyoming they shifted
their school start times from seven
thirty five in the morning to eight
fifty five in the morning much more
biologically reasonable for teenagers
the only thing more impressive than the
extra hour of sleep that those teenagers
reported getting was the drop in vehicle
accidents there was a 70% reduction in
car crashes the following year when they
made the 7-0
hosszú the advent of ABS technology for
example anti-lock brake systems that
dropped accident rates by 20 to 25
% some deemed it to be a revolution
here's a simple biological factor sleep
that will drop accident rates by 70% you
know so I think if our goal is educators
truly is to educate and we've spoken
about learning in memory and not risk
lives in the process then we are failing
our children in the most spectacular
manner with this incessant model of
early school start times why do we do
that like what and not just always cool
times but early work times too I was
driving to the airport the other day at
6 a.m. 6 a.m.
bumper-to-bumper traffic on the 405 I
was like this is insane
look at these poor [ __ ] what are we
doing and if you're in the car at 6 a.m.
there it means that you probably woke up
you know fine yeah yeah you know 30 you
know average school start times you know
in the u.s. some of them you know 7 725
buses for a school start time of 7:25
will begin leaving at 5:30 in the
morning that means that some kids are
having to wake up at 5:15 five o'clock
maybe even earlier it's just the lunacy
it is lunacy now why do they do that I
mean it's just a pattern that they've
always done and they don't they never
corrected it again it's a patent that
actually has has changed over the past
30 or 40 years I mean American schools
used to go to used to start around 9
o'clock and it started to shift ever and
ever earlier why part of it is because
of work times that parents had to get to
work it ever earlier so it's starting to
kick yeah and then bus unions and bus
schools they comply to that same time
frame as well and it becomes very
difficult you know and I'm I don't mean
to chastise school systems or the bus
unions you know it's an incredibly
difficult logistics problem but I have
to think that you know what is our goal
here if our goal is to keep our kids
safe and to get them well educated and
get information into the brain and
nurture them and you know create them to
be the next generation early school
start times you know are not the thing
to do there's a lot of lazy kids out
there they're going yes well preach on
dr. preach I mean the data you know they
look at these academic things too you
know one of these another example comes
from Edina in Minnesota and they shifted
school start times from
I think it was 725 to 8:30 in the
morning and they looked at SAT scores
and in the year before they made the
time to change the top 10% performing
students got an average SAT score of
1288 which is a great score the
following year when they were going to
school now at 8:30 rather than 7:25 the
average SAT score was 1500 that's a 212
point increase which is non-trivial Wow
that's gigantic yeah yeah I just yeah I
think it's the school time in
correlation with the work time yeah it's
very difficult to get people off of that
yeah I mean and that's part of what you
know modernity has done were were
working longer hours and also were
commuting for longer durations of time
so therefore people having to wake up
earlier they come home later
and the one thing that gets squeezed
sort of like vice grips is this thing
called sleep you know and the decimation
of sleep throughout industry eyes
nations as a consequence is having a
catastrophic impact on our health and
our wellness and the safety and the
education of our children silent sleep
loss epidemic Wow now other than making
the room cold and warming up your hands
your feet and things along those lines
Oh what about diet is it or even time
that you eat is there a specific time
before you go to bed that you should eat
how much time should you give yourself
to digest your food so the general
advice right now is don't go to bed too
full and don't go to bed too hungry
again if you're going to bed too hungry
you can get that sort of that signal of
I'm starting to go into low level sort
of starvation and that can keep people
awake at night the evidence in terms of
diet composition and sleep is quite
unclear it's not particularly well
researched area right now what we do
know is that diets that are high in
sugar and sort of heavier starchy
carbohydrates and low in fiber those
diets tend not to be good for sleep you
tend to have less deep sleep and your
sleep is also more
mented throughout the night so that's
sort of right now the best advice so you
should eat several hours before you go
to bed but not five hours that's right
yeah like two hours maybe and it's
different for different people and you
will know it you know if you're sort of
starting to wake up with really severe
hunger pangs
what about supplements like melatonin
supplements or things on those lines
melatonin is efficacious it's useful
when you're traveling between time zones
hmm so at that point your body clock
your internal clock is out of sync with
the actual real time in the new time
zone and let's say I fly from Los
Angeles over to London back home you
know my melatonin spike is going to be
eight hours in the past you know in sort
of back in time it's not going to arrive
with me for eight hours so I can take
some melatonin and I can fool my brain
into thinking oh my goodness it's
actually dark when despite in California
it's still daylight
once I've arrived through airport so you
can use melatonin strategically for
jetlag once people however are stable in
a new time zone melatonin does not seem
to be efficacious for helping sleep that
said though if people out there are
taking melatonin and they think it helps
I would tell them to keep taking it
because the placebo effect is the most
reliable affecting all of Pharmacology
so if it works for you no harm no foul
he's taking it interesting so the people
that take melatonin nightly they're like
this is what gets me go to bed really
they're just playing a trick on their
mind yeah unless you're an older
individual where you're sort of 24-hour
rhythm it's got your circadian rhythm
starts to get blunted and it's not as
strong anymore
that's where night nightly use of
melatonin actually has been demonstrated
to be efficacious but if you're young
healthy and you're taking melatonin it's
unlikely that it's actually helping your
sleep that's probably the placebo so it
really should just be just for traveling
yeah or weird situations where your
sleep is interrupted that's right and
you need to kick it into gear bring it
back on yeah so it's almost like a hack
yeah it's definitely you know that's one
way that you can hijack like I mean
there's no
you'll forget like but there's actually
lots of ways that you can hack jail like
are there any other vitamins or
nutrients or particular foods that
enhance the sleepy effect I mean there's
always the thing about tryptophan
everybody thought the tryptophan was in
Turkey yeah what I read was that was
[ __ ] and what was really going on
was that you just ate a gigantic meal
and it's filled with stuffing and mashed
potatoes and all those carbohydrates
cost you to just crash and it's usually
it's the time then everyone goes back
through instead of the living room you
lie down yeah most people chronically
sleep-deprived run finally you get the
opportunity to sort of just rest and no
one's doing anything because there's no
plans what do you think the numbers are
of sleep deprived people in this country
so we know those numbers actually almost
one out of every two adults in America
are not getting the recommended eight
hours of sleep almost one out of every
three people that you pass on the sleep
on the street are trying to survive on
six hours of or less of sleep back in
1942 Gallup did a poll and what they
found was that the average American had
built was sleeping seven point nine
hours of sleep a night now that number
most recently is down to six hours and
31 minutes for the average adult during
the week in America that's the average
by the way that means that there's a
huge swath of people well below that
average and what about the people that
say that they sleep they go to bed they
sleep five hours they wake up and they
feel great yeah so [ __ ] we have the
number of people who can survive on six
hours of sleep or less without showing
any impairment rounded to a whole number
and expressed as a percent of the
population is zero zero and one of the
big problems with a lack of sleep by the
way is that you don't know you're sleep
deprived when you're sleep deprived so
your subjective sense of how well you're
doing with a lack of sleep is a
miserable predictor of objectively why
you're doing so it's I can show you dry
man right yeah right especially yeah a
perfect example you know you're at the
bar you've had six or seven tons of time
I can drive home I'm fine
and your response is I know that you
think you're fine strive subject
objectively trust me you're not it's the
same way with sleep deprivation mmm
that's fascinating so but you're not
drunk so even though you're impaired you
don't feel like you're impaired yes and
you probably have a couple espressos or
when these caveman coffees you feel fine
right you get juiced up you're ready to
go and you're trying to accomplish
things you're trying to succeed right
you're trying to get ahead in this life
yeah honey to sleep and it's you know
that's completely country to attend
whites on the data we know that people
are more productive you know it and they
we've seen so many studies in the
workplace where you look at firstly
underslept
employees will take on fewer work
challenges overall they end up taking
the the simple ones like listening to
voice messages rather than actually
digging into deep project work hmm they
produce fewer creative solutions to
challenges that you give them they also
slack off when they're working in groups
it's called social loafing where they
just ride the coattails of other
people's hard work the less sleep that
you have the more willing that you just
sort of don't pull your weight
furthermore it goes all the way up to
the top so the more or less sleep that a
business leader has had from one night
to the next the more or less charismatic
the employees will rate that business
leader despite them knowing nothing
about the sleep of that CEO it's evident
in their behavior well because they're
short with you know they're short with
their temper they're quicker to get
upset about things or less charismatic
and social with their conversations are
just more okay I got it I got it I got
it
let's go to work work for it yeah you
know I mean less sleep does not equal
more productivity and it's always struck
me as strange you know why do we sort of
over value employees that undervalue
sleep mmm and if you look at your
workforce you know trust me everyone's
gonna be looking busy but it's like
stationary bikes
everyone's looking like they're working
hard but there's no forward progress the
scenery never changes that's what an
under septic workforce will be for you
now what about the amount of time that
people spend at work I mean
no this is not related to to sleep but
I've always felt like people work too
much I feel like you probably get more
done with less time there yeah so
efficiency is what we're talking about
and that's another one of those things
with sleep deprivation and I think many
people when they haven't had a good
night's of sleep that you know they're
looking at this report and they realized
I've just read this paragraph a third
time and I still can't quite get it was
your head scrambled yeah efficiency you
know productivity but I would feel like
when people are working eight hours a
day I don't think that you could work at
peak capacity for eight hours at least I
don't think the average person can you
can't sustain that yeah and so you're
kind of bleeding these people you're
getting blood out of a rock in the last
couple hours and it's yeah and it's not
you know either a creative way to work
in creativity you know it's supposed to
be the engine of you know business and
an ingenuity but why would you you know
take twice the amount of time to boil up
you know a pot of water on half heat
when you could do it in half the time if
you just put it on high
well that's sleep you know it's
interesting though there are certain
writers who use sleep deprivation as a
strategy for creativity they literally
don't start like the writers for a
sitcom I was on news radio they wouldn't
start writing till like 2:00 3:00 in the
morning
they would just play video games and
[ __ ] around and then late at night they
would really start writing and they
would write till like 7:00 in the
morning they would be they would stumble
into the set like barefoot delirious
hair all [ __ ] up with hilarious
scripts and it's like they had used
being silly and overtired as a strategy
almost like they were doing drugs right
they weren't doing any drugs I mean it
comes back there well I we didn't we
don't know in that scenario you know it
has me to sleep but what we have found
at least in in our scientific studies is
that that prefrontal cortex region that
we spoke about before that sort of
rational logical mud of the brain that's
one of the first things to go when
you're sleep-deprived
so that area of the brain just gets sort
of switched off right the more that you
are sort of lacking in your sleep an
emotional deep emotional centers of the
brain which are normally controlled and
kept in
check by that prefrontal cortex they
just erupt in terms of their activity so
you're all emotional gas pedal into
little regulatory control brake which
for the most part very bad but you know
one possibility is that if you want to
try and get a little bit sort of you
know crazy loosey-goosey you know maybe
that's not bad for that type of sort of
comedic writing that you you know you
become a bit more childlike and yeah I
say that affectionately because the last
part of the brain to mature in
development is the prefrontal cortex so
you revert back to almost a more
childlike State but I wouldn't I
honestly would not condone that sort of
you know undergoing sleep just based on
the mortality and you know risk of
Alzheimer's and cancer by itself you
just don't want to under slab even in
short doses I give a couple days a week
like here's the if sleep is not a
renewable resource like what is the
effect of say if you have three nights a
week where you sleep eight hours and
then the next night two hours and then
the next night eight hours how much of a
bump or how much of a dip does that two
hours give you in your overall health
it's bad it's bad so I'll give you two
examples that there's a study where they
just took individuals and they just gave
them four hours of sleep for one night
and what they saw was a 70% reduction in
critical anti cancer fighting immune
cells called natural killer cells these
are wonderful immune assassins that
target malignant cells so today both you
and I have produced cancer cells in our
body what prevents those cancer cells
from becoming the disease that we call
cancer is in part these natural killer
cells and after one night of four hours
of sleep that is a remarkable state of
immune deficiency and that's one of the
reasons why insufficient sleep predicts
cancer I could also speak about your
cardiovascular system though and all it
takes is one hour because there is a
global experiment that's performed on
1.6 billion people across 70 countries
twice a year and it's called daylight
savings time hmm
now in the spring when we lose an hour
of sleep we see a subsequent 24 percent
increase in heart attacks
what in the fall in the autumn when we
gain an hour of sleep there's a 21
percent decrease in heart attacks so
it's bi-directional that's how fragile
and vulnerable your body is to even just
the smallest perturbation of sleep an
hour one hour yeah
wow that is you're blowing my [ __ ]
mind
it's Friday I mean you can go even
further by the way you know Wow
insufficient sleep will even erode the
very fabric of biological life itself
your DNA code so in one study they took
a group of healthy adults and they
limited them to six hours of sleep for
one week and they compared the profile
of gene activity relative to when those
same people were getting eight hours of
sleep and there were two critical
results the first was that a sizeable
711 genes were distorted in their
activity caused by one week of six hours
of sleep which is highly relevant by the
way because we know that many people are
trying to survive on six hours of sleep
during the week Wow
this is second sorry No please go I was
gonna say the second sort of perhaps
more interesting result was that about
half of those genes were actually
increased in their activity the other
half were actually suppressed those
genes that were switched off by six
hours of sleep for a week were genes
related to your immune response many of
them so you become immune deficient
those genes that were increased or what
we call overexpressed
were genes that were related to the
promotion of tumors genes that were
related to long term chronic
inflammation within the body and genes
that were associated with stress and as
a consequence cardiovascular disease
this is unbelievable you know what's
really disturbing to me in my youth from
age probably I guess I was probably 18
when I started I delivered newspapers I
used to drive around and throw
newspapers out of my car and I did it
for years and I would have to be up at
five o'clock every morning and I never
never went to bed early
yeah ever and I worked 365 days a year
hello
I think I started when I was 18 I might
have been 17 whenever I started driving
I drove at 16 but I don't think I
started right away delivering newspapers
but I was trying to find a good
part-time job I think I was like either
in my senior year of high school or
after I think right after my senior year
of high school so it's probably 18 okay
and the reason I asked by the way is
because as you go through into they're
sort of later stages about license
sensitive early adulthood your
biological rhythm moves forward in time
so you want to go to bed later and wake
up later so even if you went to bed sort
of conscientiously at that time let's
say like 10 o'clock or 9 o'clock we
wouldn't be able to sleep because it's
biologically impossible yeah no I didn't
sleep in on Saturday even worse one day
a week Saturday night I'd have to get up
at 3 or 4 in the morning because I had
to deliver Sunday papers and the Sunday
papers were enormous and so I had a pack
of van filled with excited 350 people
that I would deliver papers to so I'd
had to do multiple trips so I'd start
work at you know I'd start delivering
somewhere around 435 depending on when
the papers got in and I was done by like
nine you know 9:30 then I try to crash
but I was a wreck yeah I mean and it it
[ __ ] me up for years for years I did
that and I stop and think about that now
listening to you listening to this
conversation like what kind of [ __ ]
damage that I do to myself over those
years yeah I won't tell you about the
stuff without Simas Tennant although I'd
protein and I feel okay now it's been
it's been several decades did I mention
that your subjective sense of how well
you're doing with insufficient sleep
wasn't no no wow I'm sure you did and
I'm sure that there's a factor there
what's stunning to me is that six hours
is so detrimental I would have thought
that would been fine the six hours is
good like you get six hours I that's
good that's normal for me yeah like six
hours is normal like literally the
minimum is seven yeah seven to nine
hours of sleep seven you need yeah
anything under seven is [ __ ] yep for
the for the average there is there is a
small fraction of one percent of the
population that has a special gene that
allows them to survive on about five
hours of sleep
and most people when I tell them this
they say I love that I'm one of those
people are the chances of you being you
know you're much more likely for example
to be struck by lightning in your
lifetime the odds of which I think about
1 in 12,500 then you are to have this
incredibly rare gene that means you can
survive on something around five hours
of sleep really yeah what is the gene
well it's a gene that seems to promote
sort of again wakefulness chemistry
within the brain that allows you to sort
of maintain wakefulness in a more
sustained way and so we're only trying
to understand right now what the actual
biochemical mechanisms are of in terms
of the consequence of that gene that
gene mutation but certainly it seems to
exist that there are some of those
quote-unquote short sleepers by the way
you know we hear of these business
leaders and even actually heads of state
and up in to name any names but I'll
give you right now but I'll give you two
examples of the past Margaret Thatcher
and Ronald Reagan both were vociferous
in their statement and their declaration
of how little sleep that they would get
both them said four or five hours a
night and I think in part it was to
paint this heroic ironclad status yeah
and many people would say to me Tom but
you know Margaret Thatcher your lifetime
well sadly and tragically Thatcher and
Reagan both ended up getting Alzheimer's
disease you know and we now know because
of its during deep sleep at night that
there is a sewage system in the brain
that kicks into high gear and it
cleanses the brain of all of the
metabolic toxins that have been built up
throughout the day this low-level brain
damage one of those toxic sticky
proteins that builds up us were awake
it's called beta amyloid beta amyloid is
one of the leading causes of underlying
the mechanism of Alzheimer's disease so
the less sleep that you're having across
the lifespan the more of that toxic
amyloid is building up night after night
year after year and I don't think it's
coincidental that both of them ended up
progressing into tragically into a state
of Alzheimer's disease
so it's good night sleep clean in that
way in terms of of deep sleep that's
that is stunning
are there anything is there anything you
can do in terms of how you eat or
supplements you can take that could
potentially at least somewhat mitigate
the effects of having no sleep we
haven't found any good countermeasures
have you tried diet pills so people have
tried things like epidural they fell
Amin amphetamines you know I mean
caffeine has been used strategically by
the military for years and caffeine can
help you get over the basic reduction in
your alertness so basic response times
you can you can dose with caffeine and
still maintain some degree of a fast
response under conditions of sleep
deprivation
what about provigil or new vigil you
study yes a modafinil yeah is sort of
the underlying chemical there and it's
debated who actually came up with it may
have been the French military who
actually ended up being the generators
of that that seems to work through a
pathway at least right now as we
understand it for a chemical called
dopamine and dopamine is principally
known as pleasure drug it's the chemical
that a lot of drugs of abuse will target
to sort of ramp up but it also is a
basic alertness drug that when you get
an increase in dopamine you tend to
actually get an increase in your
alertness and your wakefulness don't you
get an increase in happiness as well you
can
- although modafinil tends to come with
the alertness component of that equation
and less so with the euphoria that's why
it has a lower prevalence of sort of
addiction and abuse boy I know a lot of
people who I wouldn't say they abuse it
but they say they have to use it like
all the doctor says doctor cells are
gonna use it and I'm always suspicious
because they seem pretty normal other
than the fact that they they're
exhausted if they don't take this what's
essentially a stimulant I've taken it a
few times I've taken it when I have to
drive like long periods of time like I'm
driving from San Diego to California or
two while Los Angeles and maybe I have a
gig my gigs done at like 11:30 I know
I'm gonna be on the road late at night I
might take one and it's fine but it
gives you this weird feeling
it's a weird state and I know a lot of
tech people yeah a lot of Silicon Valley
is on this stuff and they pop it like
candy so much so that Tim Ferriss when
he was writing his book the 4-hour body
he didn't want to include it anyone
include this particular drug because he
felt like people were just gonna eat it
all the time yeah I mean and it's right
throughout student populations rook as
well as yeah yeah and I draw you know
I'm one of the interesting things is
that if you look at the the profile of
what sleep deprivation is cognitively
you know reduced alertness impulsivity
lack of ability to concentrate
difficulties with learning and memory
difficulties with behavioral problems if
I were to describe those features to a
pediatrician and say what disorder is
this probably say it's it's ADHD yes but
what we now know is that there is some
portion of children out there who are
diagnosed with ADHD who either one or
just under slept or to actually have
sleep disordered breathing because of
perhaps tonsil problems where they're
not getting sufficient sleep and when
you treat the sleep disorder when you do
a sort of you know remove the tonsils
they start sleeping normally and the
ADHD disappears Wow
so there is an issue here I think within
that sort of the explosion of ADHD not
all people are you know sort of privy to
this sort of sleep problems simply
masquerading as ADHD but some people are
that one of the other problems too
though is that ADHD kids tend not to
sleep very well and what we end up
giving them is a drug that is a
stimulant which will combat sleep and
fight back against sleep so I think we
need to have a bit more of a strategic
approach as to when we think about at
least the dose of those that medication
in terms of when sleep should be X sort
of expected during the day because you
know taking it in the middle of the day
in the evening and if it's a stimulant
it's a wake promoting drug need to be
very careful to sleep as part of that it
was that's terrifying because I don't
know if the people that are prescribing
these things have the sort of deep
education and sleep and the necessity of
it that you do they don't and you know
it's not that it's always either you
know and
in fact I've started to try and Lobby
doctors to start prescribing sleep and
don't make the mistake that that's me
suggesting you know prescribing sleeping
pills that's a separate story sleeping
pills are associated with significantly
higher risk of death and cancer and and
I'm happy to speak about that - it was
the one chapter in the book that I think
the the legal team of my publisher took
took a very long long look at but I
think doctors to come back you to your
point they on average only have about
two hours of sleep education in the
medical curriculum so 130 hours two
hours one third of the this podcast has
been two hours yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
so isn't that frightening that's
terrifying and I bet you probably have
laid things out better in this podcast
than you would get in those two hours of
education I I don't know about that but
I don't
I'll give you that credit if they could
if they could increase that you know I'm
that's really appealing for this you
know it's a third of their patients life
but they only get two hours of Education
and but the other problem is the medical
industry itself by the way you know
their residents that data you know
junior residents working a 30 hour shift
of four hundred and sixty percent more
likely to make diagnostic errors in the
intensive care unit relative to when
they're working 16 hours if you have
elective surgery you should ask your
surgeon how much sleep they've had in
that past 24 hours if they've had six
hours of sleep or less you have a 170
percent increased risk of a major
surgical error such as sort of organ
damage or hemorrhaging relative to that
same surgeon if they had been well
rested and then the irony here by the
way is that when a resident finishes a
30 hour shift gets back into their car
to drive home
there is a 168 percent increased risk
that they will get into a car accident
because of their under sub state being
ending up back in the same emergency
room where they just came from but now
as a patient from a car crash you know
it's we need to radically rethink the
importance of sleep in education in in
business in the workplace and in
medicine - why do they do that
it's a fascinating story so there's
there's a chapter here in the book on
this - it's a guy called William
holstered and he set up the first
resident surgical program in the United
States at Johns Hopkins University and
he was known for being able to stay
awake for these heroic lengths of time
days on end there is incredible like
superhuman strength turns out that in
later years after he died there was a
dirty secret
that he was actually a cocaine addict
that's son of a [ __ ] and here's what
happened it wasn't his fault yeah early
in his career he was examining the
anaesthetic capacities of cocaine so you
know if well I'm not gonna save you know
you may have heard from perhaps
colleagues that when you snort cocaine
you get an unfeasible ox nerves like I
said from colleagues I've actually never
done cocaine I have I've know quite a
few people who have and they will you
know they'll have this sort of numbness
it's the reason is because cocaine is
also a nerve blocking it yeah like
lidocaine lidocaine intercept we talked
about this yesterday ironically on the
podcast and about doctors becoming drug
addicts the initial doctors who started
doing lidocaine pulsed it was one of
them became an accidental cocaine addict
Wow he was up for days and he structured
a program where he expected his
residence to match him to go toe-to-toe
with him but remained a weird yeah it
sounds like what a cokehead would do
come on man stay awake unbelievable and
I think the story was that he actually
knew that there was a problem he went to
rehabilitation checked in under a
different surname and one part of the
regiment for him coming off cocaine was
to prescribe morphine and at the end of
the rehabilitation program he came out
with both the cocaine addiction and a
heroin addiction oh my god and so now
there's rumors you know that he would
get his shirts laundered in Paris you
know in France and you know they would
come back and it wasn't just the white
starched
you know shirts that
we're in the box that we were other
white substances too but that's you know
you ask a great question where did that
come from where's that history the
legacy seems to date back to William
Halsted who is an accidental cocaine
addict and there we have then maintained
that inhumane practice in medicine which
is like so critical to be awake and
aware and to be sharp you're cutting
people open you can operating on people
and think back to what we said you know
about being awake you know you would
never accept treatment from a doctor who
started you know looking at your child
who's sick with an appendicitis at 3:00
a.m. in the morning who then swings some
whiskey and says yeah I'm gonna do the
operations fine you would you would go
ballistic well why do we accept
treatment you know after 20 hours of
being awake you're as impaired it's you
would be if you were legally drunk so
unfortunately we placed young residents
in this position yeah of you know acting
and operating in decision-making under
conditions of insufficient sleep one in
five medical residents will make a
serious medical error due to
insufficient sleep one in 20 medical
residents will kill a patient because of
a fatigue related error craze and right
now you know there are well over 20,000
medical residents if you have a hundred
of them five we're gonna kill people
accidental deaths think about that
number that's insane
if we were to solve the sleep loss
epidemic in medicine you know we could
start saving lives and I don't know what
it is is it just a you know an old boys
network where we said well we went
through it yes so you've got to go
through it you know and that the data
now is so prolific you know I write all
about that and try to make a builder an
evidence-based you know emotional ascoli
for sleep in medicine a sleep
prescription for medicine as it were
well most people don't realize the
requirements of residents have no and
and they are they are literally you know
beyond human capacity thinking that you
know hubris and some degree of hours on
the job is going to be able to allow you
to sort of you know cut short what took
three and a half million years to sort
you know get in place which is an
eight-hour night of sleep that's just
thick-headed you know it's and I think
the medical profession it may be at the
stage where it's my mind is made up
don't confuse me with the facts Wow that
that this has blown me away I just don't
understand how the very people that are
working on the health of patients and
fixing them and repairing injuries and
taking care of diseases those are the
people that are ignoring one of the
primary factors of disease and errors
and cognitive function its its
impairment it's a travesty I have a
friend who's an ophthalmologist and he
tells the story about during his
residency he was is his back in the 80s
and he had a pager he was on the toilet
with a tray of food on his lap because
he didn't have time to eat and go to the
bathroom so his eating food and he fell
asleep and then his pager went off he's
like [ __ ] my life how many warnings
how many warning bells do you need to
tell you that you're in a dilatory state
if you sleep with your trousers around
your ankles with food or your face and
yet you're in the deeper stages of non
REM sleep and he's a guy who's working
on people's eyes yeah it's crazy yeah I
mean it's you know sleep is equally
absent for the patient in the hospital
you know setting we know that somewhere
between 50 to 70% of all ICU alarms are
either unnecessary or ignore you know
and the one place where you desperately
need the Swiss Army knife of health that
is a good night of sleep is the one
place where you get at least which is on
a hospital ward we could we could exit
people out of hospital beds earlier the
data is already there for the neonatal
intensive care unit they used to leave
bright lights on 24/7 right and that
would prevent sort of the signaling for
sleep and wake and sleep and wake and
that cycle is critical if you regularize
sleep sorry if you regular eyes light in
the neonatal intensive care unit those
infants ended up having higher levels of
oxygen saturation because they were
sleeping better their weight gain was
drum
ethically increased and they ended up
exiting the neonatal intensive care unit
five weeks earlier whoa simple things
you know why don't we do something like
this in medicine when you come into a
hospital ward you get this on an
international flight travel for free
earplugs face masks even just that by
itself could help people to start get
better sleep next on the hospital
admission form tell me when you normally
go to sleep and when you normally wake
up and to the best of our ability we as
doctors will try to sort of you know
manage your healthcare around your
natural sleep tendencies if we could do
that you know sleep is is the elixir of
life it is the most widely available
democratic and powerful healthcare
system I could ever possibly imagine why
aren't we leveraging that and taking it
that's one of the greatest hacks that
medicine could actually you know inflict
stunning how is this being received like
but by doctors are they reluctant to
listen to you I mean what would it what
is happening with all this data and
you're you're passionate cry for extra
sleep or more sleep or the proper sleep
I should say it's starting to happen I
mean when the book came out which was
sort of the hub back came back out in
back in October and and some people
started to give push back sort of in the
medicine realm you know there was some
concerns about continuity of care that
if you keep switching residents out
every 16 hours that you wouldn't have
continuous patient care and that was a
problem
well there are other medical training
systems for example France Sweden New
Zealand they do this all the time they
do not allow their residents to undergo
anything longer than either a 14 or a 16
hour shift they train their residents in
the same amount of time or less and if
you look at the rankings of their
medical health systems around the world
they rank far higher than the United
States so you can't tell me that longer
work hours for residents for example are
necessary to train good doctors the
evidence just isn't supportive so I've
had some pushback there but for the most
part I think people are receptive once
they know the information
and I think I'm the I've been the
someone who's been to blame here
I've known this evidence for you know
I've been doing sleep research now for
20 or so years we are with sleep where
we were with smoking 50 years ago we had
all of the evidence about the deathly
carcinogenic cardiovascular disease
issues but the public had not been aware
no one had adequately communicated the
science of you know smoking to the
public the same I think is true for
sleep right now that's part of the
motivation for why I wrote the book why
I've been doing or trying to do a lot of
publicity I'm a very shy person and I
don't like being in the spotlight but I
feel as though there is a mission that
whose voice has not been actually gifted
yet and I wanted to try and help and be
a sort of a sleep diplomat I mean that's
why I chose the handle on social media
trying to be there as an ambassador for
sleep and now once people start to
understand the science as we've spoken
about for two hours then people start to
actually realize it's not the third
pillar of good health alongside diet and
exercise it's the foundation on which
those two other things said you know for
example if you're dieting but you're not
getting sufficient sleep seventy percent
of all the weight that you lose will
come from lean body mass muscle and not
fat your body becomes stingy in giving
up its fat when it's underslept
so once you get this information out
there things are starting to change I've
started to have some discussions with
the World Health Organization they seem
to be very interested now in getting
getting to grips with sleep I'd love to
speak to first world governments though
when was the last time you saw any first
world nation have a government supported
public health campaign around sleep I
don't know any we've had them for you
know drink-driving for risky behaviors
you know for drugs for alcohol for
healthy eating sleep should be a part of
that equation you know I wanted Lobby
governments to start to instigate this
and it will save them millions of
dollars the RAND Corporation did an
independent survey two years ago on the
demonstrable cost of a lack of sleep to
global economies what they found was
that a lack of sleep costs most nations
about two percent of their GDP
the gross domestic product here in
America that number was four hundred and
eleven billion dollars caused by
insufficient sleep solve the sleep loss
epidemic you could almost double the
budget for education and you could
almost half the deficit for health care
Wow what studies if any have been done
on people who live in the northern
hemisphere or they experience these long
days like Alaska and Siberia places like
that it's really tough for the
regulation of the circadian rhythm yeah
and what they a lot of people they're
not all but a lot of people will suffer
from what's called seasonal affective
disorder which is the winter blues yeah
and you know it's an unfortunate acronym
you know sa D u doctor comes along you
say look I'm not feeling good it's the
wintertime
well you're sad no I know no I'm sorry
it's a medical show it's called SAT
season life it's called seasonal
affective disorder and that data is is
quite powerful too and you end up having
to use melatonin strategically to help
you fall asleep to sort of signal
darkness in the summertime when it's
really light all almost all day and then
in the winter time you reverse engineer
the trick and in the morning you sit and
you have your breakfast or you're
working at your terminal and you have
one of these big light boxes that sits
next to you strong looks power light to
try and sort of fool your brain into
thinking that you're getting a lot of
daylight when it's you know it's not
going to be light for the next four
hours so they have to undergo treatment
do they have to do vitamin D
supplementation as well some of that too
yeah because of lack of exposure for the
skin what do you V like listen man you I
think you just open up a lot of people's
minds you certainly did mine you mean
this this podcast blew me away I thought
I knew a little bit about sleep I knew
nothing thank you so much welcome tell
people how they could read your book
where can they get it what's your
website yes so I'm all over social media
and web pages
matcom and the book is called why we
sleep and it is out now on Amazon and
all major booksellers and that's
probably the best way that they can
learn all about sleep and frightening
the
living daylights out of them thank you
so much Matt I really really appreciate
it very last chip sleep well thank you
you too Thanks
[Music]